among the many celebrities who face the
Apocalypse in the 2013 comedy this is
the end was Harry Potter star Emma
Watson who in one scene was to battle a
cannibalistic Danny McBride leading
Channing Tatum on a leash hardcore man
rumors have swirled for years that
Watson walked off the set because of the
scene's content in an interview with
British GQ Seth Rogan attempted to set
the record straight he said I think
sometimes when you read something when
it comes to life it doesn't seem to be
what you thought it was but it was not
some terrible ending to our relationship
Rogan added that Watson not only came
back the next day but also helped to
promote the film of her decision to
leave the set he said she was probably
right Rogan later doubled down on the
issue on his Twitter account where he
wrote that the popular story didn't
portray the event accurately most
notably he claimed Watson did not storm
off the set as was frequently reported
Rogan tweeted scene was not what was
originally scripted it was getting
improvised changed drastically and was
not what she agreed to I'm very sorry
and disappointed it happened and I wish
I had done more to prevent it